cada vez más refugiados climáticos estos
fueron los protagonistas para
filipograndi alto comisionado de acnur
quien ha hecho una gira de 5 días por
somalia y Kenia tal vez la respuesta no
sea humanitaria es desarrollo urbano es
ayudar a las ciudades a absorber esas
grandes poblaciones Así que necesitamos
mirar hacia modelos diferentes hay mucho
debate sobre la sequía y su gestión así
como la creación de medios alternativos
por lo que también queremos traer estas
soluciones para los refugiados en el
contexto más amplio de la gestión de la
sequía de la acción climática
la sequía obligada más de un millón de
personas en somalia a desplazarse de
forma interna
durante el mes del ramadán mi esposa
murió de hambre aquí y yo quedé
indefenso todo mi ganado y cultivos
también fueron aniquilados mientras que
en Kenia los agricultores piden al
gobierno que les rescate ya que están
perdiendo su ganado
estamos sufriendo dependemos el ganado
pero ahora se puede ver como las vacas
se están muriendo y algunas no pueden
mantenerse en pie ahora no podemos
cuidar de nuestros hijos
la situación también se extiende hasta
yibuti y Etiopía el cuerno de África
vive su peor sequía en más de cuatro
décadas afectando a más de 20 millones
de personas incluidos 10 millones de
niños